Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Hello, everyone. Happy New Year, and welcome back to the recording of the live show that Dominic and I did at the Royal Albert Hall on the 18th of October. You should already have heard the episode on Mozart. And now in the second half, we are looking at Beethoven. I hope you enjoy it. The The The So The The The The The The The The The The The The 3Lz 6.60x (-1.00), 3F 5.83x (-1.00), 3S 4.83x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00),
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、新系列抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好。新年快乐，欢迎回到我和多米尼克在10月18日于皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅举办的现场演出录音。大家应该已经听过关于莫扎特的单集了。现在在下半场，我们将聚焦于贝多芬。希望你们会喜欢。
LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), LSp4 2.70x (-1.00), Please welcome back to the stage Tom Holland and Dominic Sambrough. Welcome back everybody.
请再次欢迎汤姆·霍兰和多米尼克·桑布鲁克登台。欢迎大家回来。
Always start the second half with a banger they say, and that of course was the banger to end all bangers. The first movement of Beethoven's Fifth Symphony premiered in December 1808 in Vienna, and Dominic, the opening of that movement must be the most famous opening to any piece of music ever written I'd have thought. Absolutely. So we have had Mozart, and the second half is about a very different character. Someone who is brooding, unfriendly, difficult, and... And here he is...
俗话说，下半场总得用一首震撼人心的曲子开场，而这首歌无疑就是震撼之最。贝多芬《第五交响曲》的第一乐章于1808年12月在维也纳首演，多米尼克，我想这个乐章的开场可以说是所有音乐作品中最著名的开场了吧。绝对是的。所以我们听过了莫扎特，而下半场的主角是一个截然不同的性格。一个充满沉思、冷漠、难以相处，而且……他来了……
To talk about Ludwig van Beethoven. Dominic, take it away. When I wrote that joke, I knew you would laugh. So Tom, you ended with Mozart's death and funeral in 1791. No great send-off, a slightly lacklustre occasion. And let's start by fast forwarding three decades to March 1827, to the death and funeral of his great successor Ludwig van Beethoven.
来聊聊路德维希·范·贝多芬。多米尼克，你来吧。当我写下这个笑话时，我就知道你会笑。所以，汤姆，你以莫扎特1808年（编者注：应为1791年）的去世和葬礼结束了上集。没有盛大的欢送，这是一个略显平淡的场合。让我们快进三十年，来到1827年3月，去看看他的伟大继承人路德维希·范·贝多芬的逝世与葬礼。
And it's a completely different scene. As Beethoven lies dying, also in Vienna, presents, cash, cakes are coming in from all over Europe. Beethoven's last recorded words greet the arrival from mites of a case of his favorite Rhineland wine. And his last words were, pity, pity, too late.
而这完全是另一番景象。在贝多芬垂死之际，同样是在维也纳，来自全欧洲的礼物、现金和蛋糕雪片般飞来。贝多芬生前记录的最后一句话，是迎接从迈茨（编者注：美因茨）送来的一箱他最爱的莱茵兰葡萄酒。他的遗言是：“可惜，可惜，太迟了。”
And then he died. And when he did die on the evening of the 26th of March, it was the news story of the year. So, when they held the funeral three days later, crowds had gathered outside Beethoven's apartment. There was a choir outside to see him off. The schools were all given the day off. On the way to the church and then to the cemetery, the crowds were so thick it took them ages
随后他便离世了。当他在3月26日傍晚逝世时，这成了当年的头条新闻。因此，三天后他们举行葬礼时，贝多芬的公寓外聚集了密密麻麻的人群。外面有合唱团为他送行。学校全都放假一天。在前往教堂再到公墓的路上，人群水泄不通，他们花了极长的时间
to pass through. And all the way, some of the best known people in Vienna were holding a kind of torch lit parade, most famously the young composer Franz Schubert. So clearly something had changed since the death of Mozart. And a lot of that has to do with Beethoven himself. So many of you, I guess, will already have an idea of Beethoven in your mind. The wild hair, the ferocious frowning expression,
才通过。一路上，维也纳许多最知名的人物手持火炬进行游行，其中最著名的就是年轻的作曲家弗朗茨·舒伯特。很显然，自从莫扎特去世以来，情况已经发生了变化。而这很大程度上要归功于贝多芬本人。我想你们中的许多人，脑海中可能已经有了贝多芬的形象。狂乱的头发，凶狠紧锁的眉头，
the unkempt appearance, the papers falling from his pocket, an intellectual, an artist. Mozart is fun, and Beethoven is serious. That's the stereotype. And I think this is really important because I think it is Beethoven, more than anybody else, who invents this idea of the creator, the artistic genius, as a lonely, difficult, unhappy but brilliant man. A bit like Tom. Now, one difference between Beethoven and Mozart obviously is that Beethoven is not Austrian. Beethoven is German. He was born in Bonn in the west of Germany in December 1770. Bonn was a
不修边幅的外表，口袋里掉出来的纸张，一个知识分子，一位艺术家。莫扎特充满趣味，而贝多芬严肃认真。这就是刻板印象。我认为这一点非常重要，因为我觉得正是贝多芬，比任何人都更能塑造了这种艺术创造者和天才的形象——一个孤独、难以相处、痛苦却才华横溢的人。有点像汤姆。现在，贝多芬和莫扎特显而易见的一个区别在于，贝多芬不是奥地利人。贝多芬是德国人。他于1770年12月出生在德国西部的波恩。波恩是一个
small town that belonged to the electorate of Cologne. And music was the family business. Beethoven's father was a singer, but his alcoholism stymied his career. Now as with Mozart, his father pushed him ferociously. He started giving him regular keyboard lessons when Ludwig was just five. He would make him practice until he cried. He would make him practice until he cried, he would make him practice until midnight, and he would beat him when Ludwig made a mistake. And did it work?
属于科隆选侯国的小镇。音乐是他们家的家族产业。贝多芬的父亲是一名歌手，但他的酗酒问题毁了其职业生涯。和莫扎特一样，他的父亲对他的管教极其严厉。路德维希才五岁时，父亲就开始给他安排定期的键盘课。父亲会逼着他练习到哭泣，逼着他练琴直到落泪，让他练琴练到半夜，如果路德维希弹错，父亲就会揍他。这管用吗？
Did it? No. It didn't. Because although Ludwig was clearly very good, he wasn't a prodigy on the scale of Mozart. When he reached the age of 10, he was still barely known within his own town. Nobody effectively had noticed him on a kind of continental scale.
管用吗？不管用。因为尽管路德维希显然很有天赋，但他并不是莫扎特那种级别的神童。当他十岁时，他在自己的小镇里依然鲜为人知。实际上，在欧洲大陆的范围内，没有人注意到他。
But then, at the age of 11, he got a new piano teacher, a massively important figure in his life, who rejoiced in the name of Christian Gochlob Nefer. And Nefer was a Protestant, the Beethoven's were Catholics. And Nefer was tied in to the Enlightenment. So he was full of ideas about reason and virtue and reform, full of the writings of Voltaire and Kant, and he passes these on to the young Beethoven. Now through
但随后，在他11岁时，他迎来了新钢琴老师，一个对他生命中极其重要的人物，名字叫克里斯蒂安·戈特洛夫·内弗。内弗是一位新教徒，而贝多芬一家是天主教徒。内弗与启蒙运动紧密相连。因此他满脑子都是关于理性、美德和改革的想法，充满对伏尔泰和康德著作的热情，并将这些传递给了年轻的贝多芬。通过
his Enlightenment's enthusiasm, Nefer is very well connected and one of his friends is a chap called Count Ferdinand Waldstein who lives in Bonn and is very friendly with the elector and it's Waldstein who gets Ludwig a job playing the organ for the elector. They think this is tremendous. They have great ambitions for Ludwig and
他对启蒙运动的热情，内弗拥有极广的人脉，他的朋友之一是一位名叫费迪南德·冯·瓦尔德施泰因伯爵的人，住在波恩，与选帝侯关系非常好。正是瓦尔德施泰因帮路德维希争取到了为选帝侯弹奏管风琴的工作。他们觉得这太棒了。他们对路德维希抱有宏大的抱负，
in 1787 when he's 16 years old they sent him to the city of music to Vienna. And there, legend tells, he meets the great man. He meets Mozart. And the story runs that Mozart got him to play the piano. Ludwig played, improvising brilliantly. And Mozart stood there impassively and when the last note died away Mozart said nothing he just went into the next room where his friends were sitting and he said to them keep an eye on that young man one day he will give
于是在1787年他16岁时，把他送到了音乐之都维也纳。传说就在那里，他遇到了那位伟人。他见到了莫扎特。故事说，莫扎特让他弹奏钢琴。路德维希弹奏了，即兴发挥得极其精彩。莫扎特面无表情地站在那里，当最后一个音符消逝时，莫扎特什么也没说，只是走进了朋友们坐着的隔壁房间，他对他们说：“留意那个年轻人，总有一天，他会给
the world something to talk about. And do you think that actually happened? I think that happened and that's how he spoke. That is just how he spoke. Well, maybe it did happen, maybe it didn't, but the fact the story exists at all... That's the important thing, right? The fact the story exists at all is proof of how desperate people were
世界带来轰动。”你觉得这真的发生过吗？我觉得这发生了，这就是他说话的方式。这简直就是他的说话风格。好吧，也许发生了，也许没有，但这个故事能够存在的事实本身……这才是最重要的，对吧？这个故事存在的事实，就证明了人们是多么渴望
to see a connection between them. But that first trip didn't last long. So Beethoven came home after two weeks because his mother was ill. Then in the autumn of 1792, he came back to Vienna for good. Why? Because the French Revolution had broken out. French armies were rampaging across the map of Europe, spreading perturbation and despair. The court fled Bonn. Bonn was no longer safe and Beethoven was sent to Vienna. Now of course by this point Mozart was dead. So Beethoven is going to study with that other great Austrian composer Josef Haydn and before he left Count Waldstein wrote him a note. Mozart he said is dead but Mozart's genius
看到他们之间产生某种联系。但那次维也纳之行并没有持续多久。由于母亲生病，贝多芬两周后就回家了。接着在1792年秋天，他永久回到了维也纳。为什么？因为法国大革命爆发了。法军在欧洲地图上横冲直撞，散播着惊恐与绝望。波恩宫廷仓皇逃离。波恩不再安全，贝多芬被派往维也纳。当然，此时莫扎特已经去世。所以贝多芬将师从另一位伟大的奥地利作曲家约瑟夫·海顿。在他离开之前，瓦尔德施泰因伯爵给他写了一张便条。他说，莫扎特已死，但莫扎特的天才
is still alive and is in mourning. And it is waiting for somebody. It is waiting for you. And from Haydn, you will receive the spirit of Mozart. And so off he goes to Vienna, the city where he will compose his greatest works. And I think what's so interesting about this is that a bit like Mozart, to begin with, he is better known as a player of music rather than as a composer.
依然活着，正在服丧。它在等待某个人。它在等待你。从海顿那里，你将继承莫扎特的精神。于是他前往维也纳，这座他将谱写出最伟大作品的城市。而我觉得最有趣的是，和莫扎特有点像，起初，他作为一名音乐演奏家，比作为一名作曲家更知名。
And so since he started out on the piano, let's have one of his very greatest piano pieces and we're going to hear the second movement of the fourth piano concerto, which premiered in 1808 at the same evening that saw the Fifth Symphony premiered, and we are going to hear on the piano, Mishka Rushdie-Moaman. Thank you. The The The The The I'm going to be a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
既然他是从钢琴起步的，让我们来听一听他最伟大的钢琴曲之一。我们将欣赏第四钢琴协奏曲的第二乐章，该协奏曲于1808年首演，与第五交响曲在同一个晚上首演，而我们将通过钢琴听到米什卡·鲁什迪-穆曼的演奏。谢谢。……
little bit of a The The I'm sorry. Beautiful. Beautifully played. And on that evening in Vienna when it was premiered, the piano was played by Beethoven itself. And Dominic, we've talked a lot about Vienna over the course of this evening. Shall we just focus in and describe the capital? Sure, yes. So obviously for Beethoven,
太美了。演奏得太美妙了。在维也纳首演的那个晚上，钢琴是由贝多芬本人演奏的。多米尼克，今晚我们讨论了很多关于维也纳的话题。我们要不要把焦点集中起来，描述一下这座首都？当然，可以。所以很显然，对贝多芬来说，
Vienna is much more foreign than it is for Mozart. It's the capital of the Habsburg dynasty. It is at this point by far the biggest German-speaking city in Europe with about a quarter of a million people So that's twice as big as Berlin. It's a city at war So from 1792 Austria is at war on and off for the next 22 years or so It's twice occupied by the French there are stories about Beethoven literally sheltering under his bedclothes as the shells are kind of raining down overhead and also of course is for for him it's the city of Mozart and when he arrives Mozart has been dead for a year and people are already saying who is going to be the next Mozart. You have a sense I think that if the next Mozart
维也纳比对莫扎特来说要陌生得多。它是哈布斯堡王朝的都城。此时它是欧洲最大的德语城市，人口大约有二十五万，这比柏林大一倍。这是一座处于战争中的城市。因此，从1792年起，奥地利在接下来的大约22年里断断续续地处于战争状态。它曾两次被法军占领，有故事说，当炮弹像雨点般在头顶轰鸣时，贝多芬 literalmente（字面意思）躲在被窝里避难。当然，对贝多芬来说，这里是莫扎特的城市。当他抵达时，莫扎特已经去世一年了，人们已经在说，谁将成为下一个莫扎特。你大概会觉得，如果下一个莫扎特
doesn't exist they're going to invent him anyway. And very soon after Beethoven's arrival, they say, call off the search. We have found him. In fact, after his first year, his teacher, Joseph Haydn, wrote to the Elector of Cologne, and he said, he will be one of the greatest artists in Europe, and I will be proud to call myself his teacher." And the lovely thing is that is exactly what Tom's teachers used to say about James Holland. LAUGHTER APPLAUSE
不存在，他们无论如何也会创造一个出来。在贝多芬抵达后不久，他们就说：“取消搜寻吧。我们已经找到他了。”事实上，在他到来的第一年，他的老师约瑟夫·海顿写信给科隆选帝侯，说道：“他将成为欧洲最伟大的艺术家之一，我将为自己能成为他的老师而感到骄傲。”而可爱的是，这正是汤姆的老师们过去常对詹姆斯·霍兰说的话。笑声 掌声
Sorry, Tom. Sorry. No, I'm used to this guy. I'm used to it. You deserved it after that singing. Four long years. Now he can't just be Mozart because the context has changed. For example, the way you make music is changing. Beethoven literally has different instruments to play with. For example, pianos that have a much greater range and a richer sound.
抱歉，汤姆。抱歉。不，我已经习惯这家伙了。我习惯了。你唱成那样，挨这出也是活该。漫长的四年。现在，他不能仅仅是莫扎特，因为时代背景变了。例如，你创作音乐的方式正在改变。贝多芬拥有了完全不同的乐器可以利用。例如，音域更宽广、音色更丰富的钢琴。
So if you've wondered why Beethoven might sound different from Mozart, that's one of the reasons. But even more importantly, I think, the way you make money from music has changed. So until this point, as Tom was describing in the first half, most musicians depended on aristocratic household. So Beethoven's teacher, Haydn, depended on the Esterhazy family. He lived at the Esterhazy palace over the border in Hungary. He was dressed in Esterhazy livery as effectively a servant. He was a servant. But Beethoven moves in a new world.
所以，如果你曾纳闷为什么贝多芬听起来和莫扎特不同，这就是原因之一。但更重要的是，我认为，通过音乐赚钱的方式变了。因此，正如汤姆在前半场中所描述的那样，在此之前，大多数音乐家都依附于贵族家庭。所以贝多芬的老师海顿就依附于埃斯特哈齐家族。他住在匈牙利边境的埃斯特哈齐宫殿里。他穿着埃斯特哈齐的制服，实际上就是一个仆人。他就是一个仆人。但贝多芬步入了一个新世界。
Beethoven is supported by a whole range of different aristocratic patrons, not as a servant, but as a kind of business client. So a good example of this is one of his first great patrons, who is a bloke called Prince Lychnovsky. Who was a patron of Mozart's. And they went on a kind of lads trip to Berlin, and then they kind of had a massive spat over money, as Mozart tended to do by this point.
贝多芬受到各种各样不同的贵族赞助人的支持，但不是作为仆人，而是作为一种商业客户。这方面的一个好例子是他的早期伟大赞助人之一，一个叫利希诺夫斯基亲王的小伙子。他曾是莫扎特的赞助人。他们曾一起去柏林进行了一次类似“单身汉之旅”的旅行，然后他们因金钱问题大吵了一架，正如莫扎特到了这个阶段往往会做的那样。
They did indeed. It's a to do by this point. They did indeed. It's a bit like our Restless History tours. And Lichnowski offered Beethoven an annual allowance plus board and lodging. And Beethoven said, yes, but on the condition that I'm absolutely not coming as a servant. I'm coming as somebody who is almost an equal of yours. In other words, Beethoven is very, very protective
确实如此。到了这个阶段就会闹别扭。确实如此。这有点像我们的“历史的余烬”巡演。利希诺夫斯基向贝多芬提供了一笔年津贴外加食宿。贝多芬说：“可以，但条件是我绝对不是以仆人的身份来。我是作为几乎与你平起平坐的人来的。”换句话说，贝多芬非常、非常看重
of his status and his independence. There's a very famous episode in 1808. So Napoleon Bonaparte, not a friend of the rest of his history, has set up his brother Jerome as the king of Westphalia. And to bolster his regime, a bit like a kind of Saudi billionaire with a football club, he wants to get a star player. And the star player he has in mind is Beethoven. He offers him a massive salary to come and be his Kapellmeister, his director of music. And Beethoven tells everybody this. In Vienna, of course he does, he wants a counter offer, and he gets one. Three of his patrons, Archduke Rudolf, Prince Kinski and Prince Lobkowicz, club together and they offer Beethoven an amazing deal, 4,000 florins a year for the rest of his life if he stays in Vienna and he doesn't even have to write another note.
并捍卫自己的地位和独立性。1808年发生过一个非常著名的插曲。拿破仑·波拿巴——《历史的余烬》的常驻反派——将他的弟弟热罗姆立为威斯特法伦国王。为了巩固他的政权，有点像拥有足球俱乐部的沙特亿万富翁那样，他想找一位明星球员。而他心目中的明星球员就是贝多芬。他提供给贝多芬一份优厚的薪水，邀请他去担任宫廷乐长（Kapellmeister）、音乐总监。贝多芬把这件事告诉了所有人。在维也纳，他当然会这么做，他想要一个竞标还价，他也确实拿到了。他的三位赞助人，鲁道夫大公、金斯基亲王和洛布科维茨亲王凑在一起，给贝多芬开出了一笔惊人的交易：如果他留在维也纳，每年给他4000弗林特，持续终身，而且他甚至不需要再写一个音符。
The contract says this is in recognition of his extraordinary genius as a musician and a composer. They want to liberate him from the mundane cares of earning a living so that he can get on with writing works that ennoble the arts. Now nobody had ever done this for a composer before, a deal of this magnitude. And it means that Beethoven has more security and more freedom, arguably than any composer who has ever lived to this point. He doesn't have to work to order. And this obviously goes to his head a little bit.
合同上写着，这是为了表彰他作为音乐家和作曲家的非凡天才。他们希望将他从谋生的世俗琐事中解放出来，以便他能继续创作那些提升艺术品格的作品。此前从来没有人为一个作曲家这样做过，这是一笔如此巨大规模的交易。这意味着贝多芬拥有了比迄今为止任何一位作曲家都更多的安全感和自由度，可以说是史无前例的。他不必为了订单而工作。这显然让他有点飘飘然了。
His status, his independence, means so much to him. There are two wonderful stories that illustrate this. So, one in 1806, he goes with his mate, Prince Likhanovsky, for a country weekend. There are a lot of officers staying there as well, and Prince Likhanovsky says to Beethoven, Ludwig, I would like you to play the piano for these guests. That's how Prince Likhanovsky spoke. Beethoven says, I'm not in the mood. I don't want to play. I don't want to play on cue. They have a massive row. And afterwards, Beethoven says to Prince Likhanovsky, listen, yes, you're a prince, but you are a prince because of an accident of birth.
他的地位、他的独立性对他而言意义重大。有两个精彩的故事说明了这一点。其中一个发生在1806年，他和他的好友利希诺夫斯基亲王一起去乡下度周末。那里还住着很多军官，利希诺夫斯基亲王对贝多芬说：“路德维希，我想请你为这些客人们弹钢琴。”利希诺夫斯基亲王就是这么说话的。贝多芬说：“我没心情。我不想弹。我才不要按吩咐弹琴。”他们大吵了一架。事后，贝多芬对利希诺夫斯基亲王说：“听着，是的，你是亲王，但你之所以是亲王，是因为偶然的出生。”
Very figuring. Very figuring. I am who I am because of what I have done. There are thousands of princes and there always will be. But there is and there only ever will be one Beethoven. Then, 1812, it's the kind of thing that I have to put up with from you. 1812, Beethoven and the German writer Goethe are strolling arm in arm through the park. Oh, it's like us, isn't it? Before this. Yeah, lovely. In Kensington Gardens, before this show. Exactly, exactly.
极其形象。极其形象。而我是谁，是因为我所做过的事。有成千上万个亲王，而且永远都会有。但过去曾有、未来也永远只有一个贝多芬。然后是1812年——这大概就是我不得不从你这里忍受的那种事。1812年，贝多芬和德国作家歌德挽着手在公园里漫步。哦，这就像我们一样，对吧？演出前。对，真好。在肯辛顿花园，在这场演出之前。没错，完全如此。
And they see coming towards them the Emperor Francis I and his son the Archduke. And Goethe goes to get out of the way and to bow. And Beethoven supposedly says to him, What are you doing? We don't make room for them. They will make room for us. And whether or not these stories are true doesn't really matter because what they tell you is about the image of Beethoven and the conception of him, his
然后他们看到皇帝弗朗西斯一世和他的儿子大公迎面走来。歌德准备让路并鞠躬。而贝多芬据说对他说：“你在干什么？我们才不给他们让路。他们会给我们让路的。”这些故事是真是假其实并不重要，因为它们所传达的是关于贝多芬的形象以及人们对他的构想，他
own conception of himself, not as a servant but as a star. I think he's probably the first composer who genuinely believes that every note that he writes will be played for as long as people are making music. So every work really matters. These are not throwaway commissions. They're expressions of his soul, his intellect, his genius. You look at the number of symphonies he wrote. Mozart wrote 41. Haydn wrote 104.
对自己的构想：他不是仆人，而是巨星。我想他大概是第一位真正坚信自己写下的每一个音符都会在人们演奏音乐的岁月里流传下去的作曲因此，每一部作品都至关重要。这些都不是随手应付的委约。它们是他灵魂、他的智慧、他的天才的表达。看看他写的交响曲数量。莫扎特写了41首。海顿写了104首。
Beethoven wrote just nine. Because to him, this wasn't just entertainment. It wasn't just entertainment. It wasn't something that you listened to while people were playing cards. This was art. This was serious. And the work that sums that up
贝多芬只写了九首。因为对海顿（编者注：应为贝多芬）来说，这不仅仅是娱乐。这不仅仅是娱乐。这不是你在玩牌时顺便听听的背景音乐。这是艺术。这是严肃的。而最能总结这一点的作品
is his Eroica Symphony, number three. So it was first performed in 1804. It's twice as long as any of Mozart's symphonies. Everybody agreed that it was extraordinary, a work of genius. But people also said, many of them, that it was too long. Like our series on General Custer. Like the General Custer series. Exactly.
就是他的第三交响曲《英雄》。它于1804年首次公演。它的长度是莫扎特任何一首交响曲的两倍。所有人都认为它非同寻常，是一部天才之作。但人们也纷纷表示，其中许多人认为它太长了。就像我们关于卡斯特将军的系列节目一样。就像卡斯特将军系列一样。没错。
Tom, there were mugs then and they're mugs now. But they all recognised it was a work of genius. That's what matters. But they all recognised it was a work of genius, right? Exactly. That's what matters. And people said of the Third Symphony, this is so radical, so glaring. It is a work of anarchy. And of course this has a political dimension because at the time the Austrians are fighting against people that they believe represent the forces of anarchy.
汤姆，以前有这种糊涂虫，现在也有。但他们都承认这是一部天才之作。这才是最重要的。但他们都承认这是一部天才之作，对吧？没错。这才是最重要的。人们对第三交响曲评价道：这太激进了，太刺眼了。这是一部无政府主义的作品。当然，这具有政治维度，因为当时奥地利人正在与他们认为代表无政府主义力量的人作战。
And so does this mean that Beethoven is on the side of the revolution? That's what I had always assumed, but I know your ways. Yeah, it's a little bit more complicated. Is it? It is. It always is. It always is.
那么，这是否意味着贝多芬站在革命的一边？我一直都是这么假设的，但我了解你的套路。是的，这稍微复杂一点。是吗？是的。总是这样。总是这样。
That's astonishing. So at first, Beethoven was sympathetic to the ideals of the French Revolution. And he was fascinated by the figure of Napoleon, a self-made man who blazed like a comet across the sky of Europe. And originally, a very famous story, he was going to dedicate this third symphony, the Eroica to Napoleon. But then, in December 1804, he heard that Napoleon had crowned himself emperor. And he said, what? He's just another politician. He will sacrifice the rights of man
这太令人惊叹了。所以起初，贝多芬对法国大革命的理想是同情的。他迷恋拿破仑的形象，一个像彗星一样划过欧洲夜空的自made man（白手起家者）。起初，有一个非常著名的故事，他打算将这第三交响曲《英雄》献给拿破仑。但随后，在1804年12月，他听说拿破仑自己加冕为皇帝。他说：“什么？他不过是又一个政客。他会为了自己野心的祭坛
on the altar of his ambition. He will become a tyrant. He wasn't wrong, Tom. And he rips the manuscript in two, and he scratches out the dedication to Bonaparte on the first page. So no dedication to Napoleon. But good news.
而牺牲人权。他会变成一个暴君。”他没说错，汤姆。于是他把手稿撕成两半，并在第一页上划掉了对波拿巴的献词。所以没有了献给拿破仑的献词。但是好消息。
Tom, we are and we always have been a patriotic podcast. And I'm very pleased to say that Beethoven never wrote a piece called Napoleon, but he did write one about the Duke of Wellington. And this is famously terrible, isn't it? Well, I mean, patriotic, but you've got to be honest. Why does he hate Britain? This was called Wellington's Sieg, Wellington's Victory.
汤姆，我们过去是、现在也一直是一个爱国播客。我非常高兴地宣布，贝多芬从未写过一首叫《拿破仑》的曲子，但他确实写过一首关于威灵顿公爵的曲子。而这首歌出了名的难听，对吧？我是说，爱国归爱国，但你得诚实点。为什么他要恨英国？这首曲子叫《威灵顿的胜利》，威灵顿的胜利。
He wrote it in 1813 to celebrate our brave boys' victories in the Peninsular War. Tom, you'll be pleased to hear that it incorporates both Rule Britannia and God Save the King. So the EU went for Beethoven's Ninth when they could have had that. Absolutely madness. How different history should have been. You don't hear this or the rest is politics. Um. Anyway, the following year, 1814,
他在1813年写这首歌，是为了庆祝我们勇敢的小伙子们在半岛战争中的胜利。汤姆，你一定会高兴地听到，它既包含了《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》又包含了《天佑吾王》。所以欧盟当年选《贝多芬第九交响曲》时，本来是可以选这首的。简直疯了。历史本该多么不同。你可听不到这个，也听不到《历史的政坛》。嗯。不管怎样，第二年，即1814年，
Napoleon is temporarily booted out to Elba. Vienna explodes in celebrations and festivities. There are balls, there are receptions. This is Beethoven's most successful year. It's the year in which he makes most money. It is the year in which his pieces are performed more than any other. And it is now that he stages the final version of his one and only opera, which is called Fidelio.
拿破仑被暂时踢去了厄尔巴岛。维也纳爆发出庆祝活动和节日狂欢。有舞会，有招待会。这是贝多芬最成功的一年。这是他赚钱最多的一年。这也是他的作品演出最为频繁的一年。正是在这个时候，他推出了他的唯一一部歌剧的最终版本，名叫《费德里奥》。
Brilliant. Well, let's hear a bit of Fidelio. It's the prisoner's chorus, and the two soloists are Andrew Staples and William Thomas. I'm sorry. The O, be you, O, what you do, what you do, what you do, The Lord is the Lord Wir kennen keine Gruft, keine Gruft. In front of the moon, in autumn lights, O'er him, O'er him, O'er him is the moon.
太棒了。好吧，让我们来听一听《费德里奥》的一小段。这是囚徒合唱，两位独唱演员是安德鲁·斯台普斯和威廉·托马斯。对不起。……
O'er him, O'er him, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear his scream, O hear, O hear, O hear his name. O hear the rustle, the rustle of the wind. We all trust in God's help. The the the No, we find peace. Freedom is ours! Speak quietly! Quiet!
……自由属于我们！小声点！安静！
Hold back! We are deafened with ear and sight. Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! Halt! The O, help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us, O help us O The The the the the the the Now, as you've been listening to this episode, you might have noticed that this episode had something a little extra special, didn't it, Tom? It absolutely did. And that's because every piece of music you've heard during this podcast has been performed live by the Academy of St. Martin in the Fields. And if you were there, you will remember how absolutely extraordinary their performance was.
退后！我们的耳朵和眼睛都被震聋了。站住！站住！……现在，当你们一直在收听这一集时，你们可能已经注意到，这一集有着某种特别的额外惊喜，对吧，汤姆？确实如此。那是因为你们在这期播客中听到的每一段音乐，都是由圣马丁田野乐团现场演奏的。如果你当时在现场，你就会记得他们的演出是多么的非凡。
We are thrilled to have them featured on this episode. And frankly, we're even more thrilled to be able to make that recording of that event open and free to everybody in the podcast who wasn't able to attend in person. The Academy of St. Martin in the Fields is one of the most recorded orchestras of all time, giving more than 80 concerts a year across the world, including a stunning series in London at the historic Church of St. Martin in the Fields. The Academy of St.
我们非常高兴能让他们在本集中亮相。坦白说，我们更加高兴能够将那场活动的录音向所有未能亲自出席的播客听众开放并免费提供。圣马丁田野乐团是录音最多的管弦乐团之一，每年在世界各地举办80多场音乐会，其中包括在伦敦历史悠久的圣马丁田野教堂举办的震撼人心的系列音乐会。圣马丁
Martin in the Fields is offering an exclusive, complimentary Friends membership to all listeners of The Rest is History. You can attend open rehearsals, enjoy pre-concert talks and meet and greets with soloists, access exclusive digital downloads and, crucially, receive 25% off tickets to their London concerts. To claim your complimentary Friends membership and explore all these incredible opportunities, just go to asmf.org forward slash history. So don't miss out.
田野乐团正在向《历史的余烬》的所有听众提供独家的、免费的“之友”会员资格。你可以参加公开排练，欣赏音乐会前的讲座，与独家艺术家见面问候，获取独家的数字下载，最重要的是，购买他们的伦敦音乐会门票可享受75折优惠。要领取您的免费“之友”会员资格并探索所有这些令人难以置信的机会，只需访问 asmf.org 斜杠 history。所以千万不要错过。
Visit asmf.org forward slash history and sign up today. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] today. That is a passage of music that historians have always been fascinated by because it's conventionally seen as providing the kind of the soundtrack to an age of revolution, isn't it? And just for those not familiar with the opera, to give a bit of context, it's set in Spain in the 16th century in a prison. And what you've just heard is prisoners emerging from their cells, coming blinking into the sunlight, singing of the delight they feel at their liberation.
访问 asmf.org 斜杠 history，今天就注册。……这正是历史学家们一直着迷的一段音乐，因为它通常被视为革命时代的某种配乐，对吧？对于那些不太熟悉这部歌剧的人来说，为了提供一点背景，它以16世纪的西班牙一座监狱为背景。你们刚才听到的是囚徒们从牢房里走出来，眨着眼走进阳光下，歌唱他们重获自由的喜悦。
And so it's always kind of associated with the fall of the Bastille, the overthrowing of monarchical despotism. But Dominic, I mean, as I said, I am familiar with your methods, and I kind of have a hunch that you're gonna tell me it's more complicated than that. Surprise, surprise, it's more complicated than that. So Beethoven had been working on Fidelio for years,
因此，它总是与攻占巴士底狱、推翻君主专制联系在一起。但多米尼克，我的意思是，正如我所说，我很熟悉你的套路，我有一种预感，你会告诉我事情远比这复杂。不出所料，事情远比这复杂。所以贝多芬创作《费德里奥》已经有好几年了，
and he got the idea from a French play about a bloke who's rescued from prison by his wife, but it seems pretty likely that the French play is actually set during the terror, and this bloke may be an aristocrat. And I think the politics of Fidelio may be a little bit more complicated, more conservative maybe than people think. So remember this is taking place this premiere in Vienna in 1814 in an atmosphere of conservatism, of reaction. The old order has won and at the end of Fidelio when the hero gets his freedom he doesn't get it because the
他的灵感来源于一出法国戏剧，讲的是一个普通人被妻子从监狱里救出来，但很有可能这出法国戏剧实际上是以恐怖统治时期为背景的，而这个人可能是一位贵族。我认为《费德里奥》的政治色彩可能比人们想象的要复杂一些，也更保守一些。所以请记住，这次首演发生在1814年的维也纳，是在一种保守、反动氛围中进行的。旧秩序已经获胜，而在《费德里奥》的结尾，当英雄重获自由时，他并不是因为
mob has stormed the prison, not at all. He gets it because of the intervention of the kind-hearted, benevolent governor, effectively the emperor. In other words, this is a victory for the old order. It's the old order that has prevailed. And the freedom that the opera is celebrating, Tom, in 1814, those first audiences in Vienna, to them it's freedom from the war,
暴民冲击了监狱才获得自由，完全不是。他获得自由是因为心地善良、慈悲为怀的总督——实际上就是皇帝——的干预。换句话说，这是旧秩序的胜利。是旧秩序取得了胜利。而这部歌剧所庆祝的自由，汤姆，在1814年，对于维也纳的第一批观众来说，那是免于战争的自由，
freedom from the tyranny of Napoleon, freedom from the despotism of the French from the despotism of the French. The despotism of the French. We know all about that, don't we? Because Theo, our beloved producer, is of course, well, purports to be French. Yes. Exactly, exactly.
免于拿破仑暴政的自由，免于法国专制统治的自由。法国人的专制。我们对此都很清楚，不是吗？因为蒂奥，我们深爱的制作人，当然，呃，自称是法国人。是的。没错，完全如此。
But I think there's another aspect of Fidelio that is actually more interesting. Some of Beethoven's biographers suggest that this picture of this bloke who's locked up in a prison, cut off from the outside world, is a kind of nightmarish self-portrait. Because as many of you all know, at the time that Fidelio goes on stage,
但我觉得《费德里奥》还有另一个更有趣的方面。贝多芬的一些传记作家暗示，这个被关在监狱里、与世隔绝的男人的形象，是一种噩梦般的自我画像。因为正如你们许多人所知，在《费德里奥》搬上舞台之际，
Beethoven has been going deaf for probably at least 12 years. The cruelest punishment possible for a composer. Now his death was probably started at the end of the 1790s when he's in his late 20s. We don't know really what caused it. We do know that in the summer of 1802, he went to a place called Heiligenstadt for the summer and he wrote a letter to his brothers
贝多芬的听力已经开始恶化，大概至少有12年了。对一个作曲家来说，这是最残酷的惩罚。他的听力下降可能始于1790年代末，当时他快三十岁。我们并不知道真正的原因是什么。我们确实知道，在1802年夏天，他去了一个叫海利根施塔特的地方过夏天，并给他的兄弟们写了一信，
explaining, apologizing for his horrendous form in recent months. And he said, listen, the truth is I'm losing my hearing and that one day I will be cut off from the outside world. I'll have to live like an exile in my own head. And he says, I've thought about ending it all, about ending this wretched existence. But it was my art that held me back. It seemed impossible to me to leave this world until I'd written all the works that I was capable of. And that brings us back to something that's been running through this story from the very beginning of the show, which is the idea of art as something special and something sacred, dare I say sacral, Tom. Go for it. It is art that saves us, that gives our lives meaning. And this, of course,
解释并为他最近几个月糟糕的状态道歉。他说：“听实话吧，我正在失去听力，总有一天我会与世隔绝。我将不得不像个流放者一样活在自己的脑海里。”他说：“我曾想过结束这一切，结束这悲惨的存在。但正是我的艺术支撑着我。在我写完所有我有能力创作的作品之前，离开这个世界似乎是不可能的。”这让我们回到了自节目一开始就贯穿始终的一个主题，那就是艺术作为一种特别的、神圣的事物——我敢说神圣不可侵犯的事物——汤姆。请说吧。正是艺术拯救了我们，赋予了我们的生活意义。而这，当然，
becomes one of the foundational ideas of romanticism, the idea that art is the supreme good, the summit of human existence, that it is art that makes life worth living. Now, of course, that's not much consolation to Paul Beethoven who is losing his hearing. His hearing, in fact, gets worse and worse. By 1814, the year of Fidelio, if you sit down and listen to something, and it's Ludwig van Beethoven playing the piano, you know you're not in for a brilliant evening, because he can't tell if it's been tuned properly, and he also can't tell if he's making mistakes. So actually at the end of the year,
成了浪漫主义的基本思想之一，即艺术是至高无上的善，是人类存在的巅峰，是艺术让生命值得活下去。当然，这对于正在失去听力的保罗·贝多芬（编者注：应为路德维希·贝多芬）来说并没有多少安慰。事实上，他的听力越来越糟。到了1814年《费德里奥》上演的那一年，如果你坐下来听点什么，而弹钢琴的是路德维希·范·贝多芬，你就知道今晚不会是一个美妙的夜晚，因为他分不清钢琴是否调准了音，他也分不清自己是否弹错了音。所以实际上到了年底，
he gives up playing in public, and at this point he starts carrying these conversation books. So when he meets you in the street and you're talking to him, you have to write down in the book what you're saying. So sad to say, by the mid-1810s, Beethoven has, to some extent, ended up in that dungeon. Now, he had a very unhappy and lonely love life. Some of you may know that he wrote a letter to a woman that he called his immortal beloved.
他放弃了公开演出，从这个时候开始，他开始随身携带这些交谈簿。所以当他在街上遇到你、跟你说话时，你必须把你想说的话写在册子里。所以令人痛心的是，到1810年代中期，贝多芬在某种程度上最终落入了那个地牢。现在，他的感情生活非常不幸且孤独。你们有些人可能知道，他曾给一位被称为“永恒的爱人”的女性写过一封信。
It's a great film. Gary Oldman. Which he made into a Gary Oldman film, exactly, in which he said, you know, you're the love of my life, but we can never be together. And we don't really know, again, who that was. His family life was a nightmare. For a lot of the 1810s, he's locked in this dreadful custody battle over his nephew, Carl. In 1820, he turned 50. And by this point, I think he's a very disconsolate figure, Beethoven. When he goes out, he's very scruffy and distracted. At one point, the Viennese police arrested him for being a tramp.
这是一部很棒的电影。加里·奥德曼主演的。他把它拍成了一部加里·奥德曼主演的电影，没错，他在信中说：“你知道，你是我一生的挚爱，但我们永远无法在一起。”同样，我们并不知道那个人究竟是谁。他的家庭生活是一场噩梦。在1810年代的大部分时间里，他都被卷入了一场关于他的侄子卡尔的可怕监护权之争中。1820年，他五十岁了。到了这个时候，我觉得贝多芬成了一个非常郁郁寡欢的人。当他外出时，他衣衫褴褛、心不在焉。有一次，维也纳警察甚至因为他像个流浪汉而逮捕了他。
And part of the problem, of course, is they're talking to him and he can't hear what they're saying. It's a bit of a problem. But the weird thing is that all this is actually great news for the Beethoven brand. Because it perfectly captures the ethos of the Romantic Age, the idea of a lonely hero who is battling with his demons in a kind of spiritual exile. Now, all the time, Beethoven is still making music. He is making music that is more demanding, more challenging than ever before. Some people say it's too challenging.
当然，部分问题在于他们跟他说话，而他听不见他们在说什么。这确实是个问题。但奇怪的是，这一切对贝多芬的个人品牌来说其实是个极好的消息。因为它完美地契合了浪漫主义时代的精神风貌，那种在精神流放中与心魔搏斗的孤独英雄形象。与此同时，贝多芬仍在创作音乐。他创作的音乐比以往任何时候都更加深奥、更具挑战性。有些人说这太具挑战性了。
So you have a sense of an emerging breach between the masses who like the kind of fun, easy operas that are coming from Italy, and the connoisseurs who think that if it's difficult, that means it must be profound. And Beethoven himself was in no doubt about who he was writing for. He said, I don't write for the masses. I write for people who are cultured, like you. But even though people find his stuff very difficult, they never doubt that Beethoven is a star. And by the 1820s, he really does have a brand. People are painting his portrait, they're making busts of him. Images of Beethoven are going all over Europe
所以你会感觉到，喜欢来自意大利的那些轻松有趣歌剧的大众，与那些认为只要晦涩就一定深刻的鉴赏家之间，正在出现一道日益扩大的鸿沟。而贝多芬本人对于他是为谁写作这一点毫无疑问。他说：“我不为大众写作。我为有文化的人写作，就像你们这样的人。”尽管人们觉得他的东西很难懂，但他们从不怀疑贝多芬是一位巨星。到了1820年代，他确实拥有了一个个人品牌。人们在画他的肖像，为他制作半身像。贝多芬的形象传遍了全欧洲
and they're appealing to people who had never really existed before in the history of classical music. They're not admirers, they're not supporters, they're not patrons, they are fans. And that word is coming from fanatics, isn't it? They're fanatics. Fanatics for Beethoven. Yeah, absolutely. And I think part of the reason for this
而且他们吸引的正是古典音乐历史上从未真正存在过的一群人。他们不是崇拜者，不是支持者，不是赞助商，他们是粉丝。这个词源于“狂热者”对吧？他们是狂热者。贝多芬的狂热者。是的，完全如此。我认为部分原因在于
is that Beethoven's image perfectly fits the demands of the times. This is a conservative age, an age of reaction. So people love the idea of tradition. They love the idea of Beethoven as the culmination of a tradition that began with Mozart and Haydn. But what's more, his German-ness is really important. The French Revolution was a foundational moment in the history of German-ness. That moment when French troops cross the Rhine is when modern German identity is born.
贝多芬的形象完美契合了时代的诉求。这是一个保守的时代，一个反动的时代。所以人们热爱传统的理念。他们热爱贝多芬作为由莫扎特和海顿开创的传统之巅峰的理念。不仅如此，他的德国属性也非常重要。法国大革命是德国属性历史上的一个奠基时刻。法国军队跨过莱茵河的那一刻，就是现代德国身份诞生之时。
So people are looking for a German hero and Beethoven perfectly fits the bill. But all the time his health is getting worse. By the end of 1826 he's got pneumonia, he's got jaundice, he's got liver issues and of course he can barely hear anything at all. But apart from that he's doing fine. Yeah. Apart from that, he's in great form. Now, we described his final days earlier, the presents and the wine and whatnot. But sad to say, on the 26th of March, 1827, in the middle of a tremendous thunderstorm, he takes his final breath. And it is said that at the very end, he opens his eyes, he lifts his right hand to heaven,
因此人们在寻找一位德国英雄，而贝多芬恰好完全符合。但与此同时他的健康状况却在恶化。到1826年底，他得了肺炎、黄疸、肝脏问题，当然他几乎什么也听不见了。但除此之外他状态好得很。是的。除此之外，他状态好极了。现在，我们刚才描述了他最后的日子，那些礼物和美酒之类的。但遗憾的是，在1827年3月26日，在一场巨大的雷雨中，他咽下了最后一口气。据说在生命的最后时刻，他睁开双眼，将右手举向天堂，
he clenches his fist, and then he collapses. The artist defiant to the end. So a sad, I want to say a tragic moment, and to mark it, let's now hear perhaps the most celebrated thunderstorm in the entire history of classical music, and it comes from the Sixth Symphony, the Pastoral and we are going to hear the fourth movement which gives us a thunderstorm
他紧握拳头，然后倒了下去。这位艺术家直到最后都充满抗争。所以这是一个悲伤的，我想说是一个悲剧性的时刻，为了纪念它，现在让我们来聆听古典音乐史上也许最著名的雷雨，它出自第六交响曲《田园》，我们将听到第四乐章，其中有一场雷雨
and then right at the end the hint of a rainbow. The The The The The The The The The The So Dominic, we began this half with the funeral of Beethoven, and lo and behold, we've come full circle. Exactly, Tom. It's almost as if we'd scripted it. And as we said before, his death was an extraordinary public occasion. People were literally queuing up to take snippets of hair from his head to wear in lockets around their necks like religious relics. Now, there was a very revealing eulogy at the cemetery gates and it was made by Vienna's greatest playwright, a man called Franz Grillparzer. Tom, are you familiar with his work? I'll be honest, it sounds like an American steak restaurant rather
然后在最后隐约出现了一道彩虹。那么多米尼克，我们以贝多芬的葬礼开始了前半场，看吧，我们又回到了原点。完全如此，汤姆。简直就像我们写好的剧本一样。正如我们之前所说，他的死是一场非凡的公众盛事。人们排着队从他头上剪下一缕缕头发，戴在脖子上的小盒里，就像圣物的遗物一样。现在，在墓地大门有一篇极具启发性的悼词，由维也纳最伟大的剧作家弗朗茨·格里尔帕策发表。汤姆，你熟悉他的作品吗？说实话，这听起来像是一家美国牛排餐厅，而不是
than a great writer. It doesn't encourage me to want to read it, I have to say. Well, Grillpartzer in the eulogy did not mention God at all. Extraordinary. He mentioned only the gods of music and art. He was an artist, he said of Beethoven. That's how he spoke again. That's how all Germans speak when they're talking about art, Tom. And all that was his was his through art alone. He was an artist, and who shall arise to stand beside him? Who, indeed? And this, I think, was Beethoven's greatest legacy.
一位伟大的作家。我得说，这并不能激发我去阅读它的欲望。嗯，格里尔帕策在悼词中根本没有提到上帝。非同寻常。他只提到了音乐和艺术之神。他说贝多芬是一位艺术家。他又是这样说的。所有德国人在谈论艺术时都是这么说的，汤姆。他所拥有的一切，仅仅通过艺术就获得了。他是一位艺术家，谁又能站出来与他并肩？又有谁呢？我想，这就是贝多芬最伟大的遗产。
You talked about Mozart as a genius. I think what Mozart, what Beethoven, rather, creates is the idea of the artist with a capital A. The individual who suffers and overcomes. The martyr, the man who stands alone from the masses. Somebody whose work, like mine, is long and difficult and therefore profound. Tom, he can see things and hear things that you and I can't. Well, he can't actually hear them, can he?
你把莫扎特称为天才。我认为莫扎特、或者说贝多芬所创造的，是大写A的“艺术家”的概念。那个承受苦难并最终战胜苦难的个体。殉道者，那个独立于大众之外的人。某个其作品像我的一样漫长而艰难、因而深邃的人。汤姆，他能看到和听到你我所看不到的东西。嗯，其实他根本听不见，对吧？
I mean, that's the whole point. No, that's true. We'll always have that over Beethoven, won't we? So let us end with the passage that for many people represents the climax of Beethoven's genius. Beethoven began his Ninth Symphony in 1822, and at its heart is Friedrich Schiller's Ode to Joy, which he'd first written in 1785,
我的意思是，这正是关键所在。不，这倒也是。我们在这方面总能压过贝多芬，不是吗？所以让我们以那段对许多人来说代表了贝多芬天才巅峰的乐章来结束。贝多芬于1822年开始创作他的第九交响曲，其核心是弗里德里希·席勒的《欢乐颂》，他最初于1785年写下它，
a kind of hymn to enlightenment values. As always, it's a complicated story. Wow. Schiller was horrified by the excesses of the French Revolution. He was horrified by the execution of the king and the terror, and he actually toned down his original Ode to Joy to make it less radical, to make it more conservative.
一种对启蒙价值观的赞歌。和往常一样，这是一个复杂的故事。哇。席勒对法国大革命的过激行为感到惊恐。他对国王的处决和恐怖统治感到惊恐，他实际上淡化了他最初的《欢乐颂》，使其不那么激进，更加保守。
And this is the version that Beethoven used. But my favourite story about the Ode to Joy and about the Ninth Symphony is one that many of you will know. Lots of you who know the story of Beethoven will know this story. Because when the symphony was first performed in 1824, Beethoven stood at the front waving his arms next to the conductor, even though he could not hear a note. And when it was all over,
这就是贝多芬使用的版本。但我最喜欢的一个关于《欢乐颂》和第九交响曲的故事是许多人都知道的。很多了解贝多芬故事的人都会知道这个故事。因为当这部交响曲于1824年首次演出时，贝多芬站在前台，在指挥旁边挥舞着手臂，尽管他一个音符也听不见。当这一切结束时，
he couldn't hear the applause behind him. And very gently, the singer Carolina Unger turned him round so that he could see, but not hear, the standing ovation. Brilliant, Dominic, thank you. And we have some ovations of our own to give. An ovation to the Royal Albert Hall for hosting us, to the Academy of St Martin in the Fields, wonderful, wonderful orchestra,
他听不到身后的掌声。歌唱家卡罗琳娜·恩格非常温柔地把他转过身来，让他能够看到而不是听到全场起立鼓掌。太棒了，多米尼克，谢谢你。我们也有一些自己的掌声要送出。向主办我们的皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅致敬，向圣马田室内乐团致敬，这是一个美妙绝伦的乐团，
to the Philharmonia Chorus, its chorus master Gavin Carr, to our wonderful soloists Nardis Williams, Katie Stevenson, Andrew Staples, William Thomas, Mishka Rashdi Moeman. But I think above all we owe a debt of thanks to the great guiding spirit behind this entire evening, the man whose idea it was, the wonderful Oliver Zephman. APPLAUSE And Tom, let's be honest, it's hard to admit it, but we would be nothing without our own aristocratic sponsors. So a huge thank you to Tony Pasta and Jack Davenport, the Habsburg emperors of our hearts. Thank you to our Viennese aristocratic patrons, the brilliant Tabby
向爱乐合唱团及其合唱指挥加文·卡尔致敬，向我们出色的独唱歌手纳尔迪斯·威廉姆斯、凯蒂·史蒂文森、安德鲁·斯台普斯、威廉·托马斯、米什卡·拉什迪·穆曼致敬。但我认为最重要的是，我们必须感谢整个夜晚背后伟大的精神指引者、那个提出这个想法的人，美妙的奥利弗·泽夫曼。掌声。汤姆，说实话，这很难承认，但如果没有我们自己的贵族赞助商，我们将一无所有。所以非常感谢托尼·帕斯塔和杰克·达芬奇，我们心中的哈布斯堡皇帝。感谢我们的维也纳贵族赞助商、才华横溢的塔比
Cyrett and Anoushka Lewis and to our Parisian friend the peerless Theo Young Smith and all of their colleagues a Goalhanger podcast. And of course a huge huge thank you to all of you for coming and for your encouragement with this. I think it's been an amazing evening. It's been a privilege to be sat up here listening to this incredible music, so thank you. APPLAUSE
赛雷特和阿努什卡·刘易斯，感谢我们的巴黎朋友、无与伦比的西奥·杨·史密斯以及高悬播客的所有同事。当然，非常非常感谢你们所有人的光临以及对这档节目的鼓励。我认为这是一个美妙的夜晚。能够坐在这里聆听这不可思议的音乐是一种特权，所以谢谢你们。掌声
And now, to play us out, it's over to Oliver and to Ludwig. CHEERING AND APPLAUSE Thank you. In the treetop fire-cruiser, In the shirtline high-roof, Final summer in the river, Must be more extreme than today. The hallowed mansion, With the greener, The cool and soft, The greener, the white.
现在，作为尾声，交由奥利弗和路德维希呈现。欢呼与掌声。谢谢。在树梢的火巡舰中，在高高的衬衫线屋顶上，河中的最后一个夏天，必须比今天更加极端。神圣的宅邸，伴随着更绿的色彩，凉爽而柔软，更绿的色彩，白色的色彩。
Final summer in the river, Must be more extreme than today. The Zeit und Stunde, Millionen, diesen Kuss der ganzen Welt. Thee we praise, thee we praise, Thee we praise, thee we praise, The Vater Wangen! Rede! Rede! Spermelswelt! Ust uns, mein Kiemen! Vater Wangen! In heaven, God help our family. O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, Du bist nur der Schöpfe, Welt, The stars are shining, we are shining from heaven. The Lord is risen. So let us all sing. We will fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight on, fight The The The The Friede! Friede! The The The and heaven, or my soul, to the free heart.
河中的最后一个夏天，必须比今天更加极端。时间与时刻，千百万人，献给全世界的这个吻。赞美你，赞美你，赞美你，赞美你，父亲的脸颊！说话！说话！精子世界！在我们之中，我的鳃！父亲的脸颊！在天堂，上帝保佑我们的家庭。噢，来吧……（重复）……你只是造物主，世界，繁星闪耀，我们从天堂闪耀。主已复活。所以让我们一起歌唱。我们将继续战斗……（重复）……和平！和平！……还有天堂，或是我的灵魂，走向自由的心。
Give it to the Prince of the Fiend, and he'll rest it on his grave. The Oh, thy smile! The night of the blessed night. I'm We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world!
把它交给恶魔王子，他会让它安息在他的坟墓上。噢，你的微笑！祝福之夜的夜晚。我们是世界的冠军！……（重复）
We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! We're the champions of the world! The The land that our forefathers built, The land that our forefathers built, And the champiment and the series coming out next Monday will be on the Nazi's Road to War. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是世界的冠军！……（重复）我们先辈建立的土地，我们先辈建立的土地，下周一即将播出的系列节目将聚焦纳粹的战争之路。再见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。